do you really believe that January 6 was
a peaceful protest would you really call
it that considering people breaching
police lines some people were armed
there were broken windows people wanted
to hang my Pence why do you really
consider it a peaceful protest I I
didn't call it a peaceful protest I
referred to the pro-life Advocates
outside of s Angelo's abortion clinic as
peaceful protesters what I said of the
January excuse me January 6ers is that
they were largely not violent at all not
one of them brought any weapons there
was no plan of insurrection or anything
like that and the most famous faces from
that day were actually escorted in by
the Capitol Hill Police and were given a
private tour much most of what we were
told about that day was just a Flatout
lie now this doesn't mean that all of
them or most of them acted appropriately
it doesn't mean that they didn't commit
some kind of transgression I joke about
them being arrested for cracking a Coors
Light in the Capitol rotunda but I
suppose you're not supposed to crack a
course light in the capital rotunda and
so there should be some proportional
sort of punishment for that but there
isn't